between roles like harley quinn tanya
harding and sharon tate when you have a
part that requires an iconic diva you
call margot robbie but what happened on
the set of the wolf of wall street that
was too much even for this megastar keep
watching to find out during production
on the wolf of wall street margot robbie
joined a long list of actors who filmed
love scenes they eventually regretted
playing naomi lapaglia the fictional
second wife of millionaire stockbroker
jordan belford robbie found a variety of
sensual scenes
however the scene that most stood out
for the australian actress was one where
naomi and jordan played by leonardo
dicaprio make love on a bed of cash like
most film productions fake cash was used
to film the scene and the bills produced
by famed movie money maker rjr props
left robbie with an unusual cautionary
tale to share in a 2017 interview with
the daily beast she warned i got a
million paper cuts on my back from all
that money it's not as glamorous as it
sounds if anyone is ever planning on
having sex on top of a pile of cash
don't
yep you heard that right robbie suffered
battle scars from rolling around in
money apparently the texture of movie
money is different from the real thing
and everyone on set that day found out
exactly how much of a difference a small
change in texture can make in her
interview with the daily beast robbie
reflected maybe real money is a bit
softer but the fake money is like paper
and when i got up off the bed i turned
around to get my robe and everyone
gasped i said what is it and they said
you look like you've been whipped a
million times your back is covered in a
thousand red scratches if only that was
the height of excitement during robbie's
wolf of wall street experience turns out
margot robbie's uncomfortable love scene
with co-star leonardo dicaprio was one
of many that stuck with her after the
camera stopped rolling the wolf of wall
street star also revealed to the daily
beast which scene was the most bonkers
to film
every single scene was absolutely insane
definitely the quaalude scene i remember
sitting there going i will never ever
film a scene like this again we doubt
you've forgotten this once in a lifetime
sequence but if you need a refresher the
quaalude scene occurs in the hectic
final act of the wolf of wall street
when jordan drives out to his country
club to make an important call while on
the phone he discovers the seemingly
expired quaaludes he took with jonah
hill's donny were in fact still active
as the effects of the drugs kick in
jordan realizes his shady business
dealings have gotten him in serious
trouble and he springs into action to
get himself out over the course of a
hysterical 10 minutes an extremely high
jordan crawls his way back to his car
drives home yells at an equally high
donny for double-crossing him and then
saves donnie as he starts choking to
death on a piece of ham meanwhile a
pregnant naomi is left to watch and
worry it's no wonder the scene left such
a big impression on robbie she recalled
to the daily beast i'm sitting there as
naomi eight months pregnant and leo and
jonah are crawling around trying to
strangle each other and i had to try not
to laugh because they looked so
ridiculous
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite hollywood blockbusters are
coming soon subscribe to our youtube
channel and hit the bell so you don't
miss a single one
[Music]